okay ladies Gemma can I ask you to take
your seats and we can get to our next
panel with our two experts one of whom
comes to us from the Polish Embassy in
Washington DC his name is matcha a pasar
ski mr. piece-of- ski will probably go
first and he will talk about some aspect
of Poland's foreign policy today as you
know this is a little bit dangerous in
the sense that the new Polish government
is only just beginning to develop its
priorities in this area but there have
been some statements made and I'm sure
that mr. Prasad ski will be able to give
us an idea of the direction that foreign
policy planners in Warsaw our thinking
our second speaker who I also will now
very briefly introduce is Professor NJ
hitachi mobe who is teaching this
academic year at Columbia University
thanks to the semper bologna foundation
and the Kosciusko foundation he is a
distinguished visiting professor from
Warsaw University and he's teaching
courses on Poland and the EU and also
Poland and common security and defence
policy foreign policy sorry and this is
something that I think we will be seeing
much more of as time goes on how Poland
fits into a pan European context and
also then how that either connect sir
doesn't connect with transatlantic
policy so let me ask mr. pesados key to
go first and mr. Posada ski let me also
remind you that there are senior polish
diplomats in this
if you want to keep your job be very
careful what you say thank you very much
professor in skill good afternoon ladies
and gentlemen it is a great pleasure for
me to be here today and I talk during
this outstanding conference well first
of all let me let me let me recognize
the door there are several señor
diplomats of polish diplomat cell here
which are you know much more fitted than
me to address to today's topic and this
is ambassador at of Pekin Consul General
Custer can I also welcome other
colleagues from from the UN mission and
publish consulate general there is it
has a tremendous tremendous challenge
for me to speak after professor Jessie I
can't think about anything which which
which could it could be a kind of
fitting total to what what what what he
said let me just give you remarks and
please treat them as a kind of footnotes
to what Professor J James Ghia has said
just minutes ago indeed wha as you know
Poland has has a new government and the
the Prime Minister has lay out the
platform of his cabin cabinet only week
ago as to the foreign policy if he
expressed the desire to continue
pursuing these strategic priorities
which have reminded reminded constant
for more than a decade he stressed the
importance of euro-atlantic cooperation
as a primary area for the achievement of
of Poland's interests he stated that the
integration within these structures of
the European Union is a guarantee of
Poland's development and
priority and the alliance with the
United States within the framework of
NATO is a guarantee of our security he
also emphasized that these majors major
components are not competitive but a
complementary in nature so as you can
see this is a very classic statement of
the foreign policy goals and the strong
emphasis on or on the continuation for
all these years of the democratic
transformation ad fundamental goals of
Polish foreign policy have reminded we
have remained clear and stable moreover
they were a sub subject to a national
consensus it gave the polished political
class a strong support for pursuing them
to secure the sovereignty and and better
international environment conducive to
the development of our economy as you
know opponent is now a member of NATO
and European Union and so that means
that the the goals which are which were
stated at the very beginning of the
transformation have been accomplished
and this is rightly a huge success of
Poland and its foreign policy before I
will talk more about the priorities of
the Polish foreign policy let me just
share with you some some of my remarks
on the general overall ramification of
the of where Poland is in terms of
foreign policy after the after the EU
and NATO membership well i think that
the polish foreign policy has arrived at
a new phase in its contemporary
development a stronger engagement in
europe european
policies will have impact on our
relations with other international
partners a closer interaction with the
European institutions will of course
influence and actually it's happening
the way in which the agenda of the
Polish a foreign policy is being
formulated true through the membership
in NATO and EU Poland has gained access
to the decision-making processes that
shape the the Euro that shape Europe and
the transatlantic am area nevertheless
the integration brings also some new
challenges and let me now just briefly
enumerate some of them I understand that
this is these are just examples not the
clothes list and it can be also treated
as the addition to the challenges
professor objects in skier has spoken
about well in this new environment a
Poland has to define its new Pollock its
new goals in the relations with with our
web it's the major partners in a sense
that they should strengthen our position
within the transatlantic institutions
while securing a full national consensus
for the foreign policy goals might not
be so easy as in the past in that
environment then opponent has to address
the growing interdependence between the
domestic and foreign policies besides
the society expects that the foreign
policy will provide more tangible
benefits student to to ordinary citizen
whether it is about easing the travel
restrictions or providing more
opportunities for work or studying
abroad those who will shape the foreign
policy in Poland have to be
prepared to address such expectations at
keep them on the level where they can be
met the European integration brings
about a dilemma of seeding more national
sovereignty to supranational
organizations and this is of course a
very complex issue for poor country like
Poland which regained its full
sovereignty only 16 years ago the
pollens position on the international
scene will not only depend on its
political and economic powers but also
on its capabilities to form alliances
especially within the EU this requires
an ability to settle for compromises and
a precise understanding of the limits of
acceptable compromises in a in any case
I think that these challenges cannot
cannot impact undermine the fundamentals
of the Polish foreign policy which is
which is of course securing a strong
transatlantic link due to the experience
of the 20th century Poland has added to
its European identity a strong
trans-atlantic vocation well there are
four di a dilemma with Europe or with
the United States sounds pretty alien to
us in fact it is it is it is seen in
Poland as unreasonable and even
destructive Poland supports American
leadership in reshaping the
international system Europe too should
be actively engaged in that process we
perceive the American role as an asset a
force for a positive change the United
States has the potential for for such
leadership but for this however to be
effective it it has to be inclusive
and based on the principles acceptable
by the members of the international
community at least by those who are who
adhere to the democratic values despite
the job political changes brought by the
demise of communism Europe remains
important for America and its security
it would be a big mistake to assume that
Europe no longer matters to meet the
challenges of all the 21st century
America has to have allies the only
genuine ally are with whom America
shares fundamental values and interests
is the european union with its potential
in economic political and in the future
probably also military capabilities the
EU is an attractive partner for the
united states to promote stability
democracy and prosperity in most
volatile us for volatile regions of the
Middle Eastern Eurasia Poland will
continue to advocate for a greater
transatlantic cohesion while rejecting
any attempt to build a European unity on
anti-american sentiments of course we
are worth the differences in opinion
between the United States and some of
European European countries are kind of
natural phenomenon after all we are
talking speaking about the community
composed by of a democratic nations with
the absence of a looming danger as for
instance during the Cold War such
differences are likely to surface
probably even more frequently but we
need to learn how to deal with them
without undermining the transatlantic
construction any any European policy
built on anti-americanism well-known
fact will not function in Europe in fact
it will produce a great deal of friction
between the EU members and possibly
putting
the whole European great European
project Poland recognizes the necessity
for NATO to transform itself in order to
remain relevant in the era of new
threads no other military alliance in
the in the history has proven to be more
successful than than NATO as we know at
present there is there is no serious
threat of a major military conflict in
Europe although we should not forget
that the NATO is still playing a pivotal
role in providing the security in the
parts of the Balkans while the
international efforts to handle the
issue of the status of Kosovo are
accelerating nevertheless it does not
mean that that we can take our security
for granted and i think that the
prosecution's key made a strong point in
that in that field sources are the
sources of possible threats are located
these days mostly outside europe and
nato has to be ready to contain them
before it is too late therefore the
Alliance has to possess efficient
political and military capabilities to
act beyond the continent taking a
greater responsibility for the
stabilization in Afghanistan shows that
NATO is developing in in this direction
and the prime minister during his speech
in the parliament I think said that that
that Poland will be will be ready to
take over the command of the NATO
operation in Afghanistan provided the
Alliance gives some logistical support
the is is also playing an active role in
Iraq and and we hope it will continue to
do this to do so again opponent support
supports NATO's an engagement outside
Europe
but for us the bottom line here is that
that NATO NATO's primary goal remains
the collective defence the task of the
democratic transformation in Europe is
not over yet there is still plenty of
unfinished business above all the
modernization of Eastern Europe
including the anchoring of Ukraine in
the Western family the issue of Belarus
has been gaining the importance of over
the last over the last several months to
handle all these problems properly we
need to have a strong strong common
strategy between the United States and
Europe just believe that that these are
very important tasks for the
transatlantic community that could that
put reinvigorated the orange revolution
in Ukraine showed that the society has
spoken out for the democracy Poland has
worked with the United States to
encourage Ukraine's closer integration
with the West including NATO and WTO we
have also advocated the Ukrainian cause
within the EU encouraging the
development of the action planner
encouraging to look for ways to ease the
existing visa regime and to grant
Ukraine the market economy stages it
gives us a great deal of hope to see
that United States and European
institutions are engaged in facilitating
a democratic change in Ukraine
nevertheless Ukraine still needs a lot
of support from us but it also provides
the transatlantic community for a unique
opportunity to demonstrate its
credentials as the main engine for
reform for free
and democracy in the most sensitive
regions in Europe and beyond Poland is
also vitally interested in developing a
more coherent European policy towards
Russia which would include also such
issues like energy and trade let me say
a few sentences about about the Polish
American relations as you as you as you
know are the contacts between opponent
and the US have reached in the recent
period an unprecedented level we have
reason to believe that the United States
regards Poland as one of its closest
allies and we are very much interested
that it becomes a kind of firm and
constant element of the u.s. foreign
policy the Polish support for the us-led
military action in Iraq and our role in
the stabilization process demonstrated
that Poland is a credible and long-term
a lie it gives also Poland and
opportunity to play more active role in
the international relations probably
greater than then it is reserved for for
country of a similar like Poland
potential in economy and and the
military sphere we hope that the
situation in Iraq will will normalize
and to the extent that it would not
longer demand a larger military presence
and allow us to change the character of
our mission there the bottom line is
doubt that Poland sticks to its
commitments
we also believe that that the Polish
American alliance is a good investment
for the United States as such it needs
to be reinforced and solidified and
never taken for granted our political
relationship has has been developed has
to develop in the first place into a
network of dance contacts and
consultations you should it should be
enriched by an extensive cooperation in
various various levels between both the
state and non-state sectors an important
step has been made in this regard by
launching a Polish American strategic
dialogue last year in addition we have
identified four major areas of
cooperation that provide a great
opportunity for the development of our
bilateral ties and these are in
increasing the military cooperation and
and the American assistance for the
transformation of the Polish Armed
Forces developing economic relations
especially in the field of investment
and Technology and boosting the
people-to-people contacts by easy into
the existing travel regulations and
ultimately including Poland into the
visa waiver program and expanding the
cooperation in science and scientific
exchange and let me finish at this point
and
Thank You mr. chairman and ladies and
gentlemen has been said already that
might be killing for the speaker to
deliver after professor jasinski but in
this case if it is easy to speak after
police emergency because one could dream
up from having having such introduction
it all depends on what you're going to
say and I that will be at those of
Correspondence actually because in
between between our interventions and
here and I gave a title to my
presentation and poems find security
policy 1989 and 2005 and subtitle is are
we really confronted with two options
and I will concentrate my remarks on
what I think is central issue of
Poland's foreign and security policy in
2005 and the question is how to combine
our commitments in NATO and European
Union in more harmonious way they on my
side this will be other invitation to
father thinking and to discussion them
than one and only concept that it will
be rather normative than descriptive in
character but I think that did this
problem of the harmonious coordination
of being member of two sad speak
organization is essential problem for
poems for him and security policy and I
think that we will lack a serious debate
on this topic and in my country so to
start but I think that the first period
after 18 of the 1981 after this year of
Warner was a great remarkable success in
Poland's foreign policy one might say
that Minister consists of
Kubasaki who who was in charge of pollen
foreign policy for four years was a sort
of Polish ball Tsarevich in forum in
foreign policy he made all this dramatic
if not trusting changes but without the
shock therapy happily without the shock
therapy the the breakthrough was managed
in very smoothly well thing over and in
very pragmatic in very pragmatic and
successful successful way imagine
escaping from communist system and from
walsall part from comic-con and having
reuniting germany on one border having
how to go disintegrating a disunited
soviet union on another on another
border and the borders the old borders
all states change around you and and to
do it without one shot without one big
crisis and with with a huge success in
the end so poland promote the promoted
policy based on european democratization
and integration and made preparatory
steps to future membership in NATO that
all was done during the first period of
ministers kucharski in charge in
Poland's foreign policy all lessons from
the past were learned and conclusions
were taken to enemies doctrine was
replaced by good neighborhood good
neighborhood doctor but friendly
neighborhood doctrine the remnants of
Soviet Union on eastern Poland border
were converted into assets for the first
time we had on our eastern border post
Soviet but the Russian state Ukrainian
state lithuania that was not for the
first time goes but yellow Russian state
and Ukrainian state and ha and and the
policy applied told those two countries
we're very pragmatic were friendly and
was made with sensitivity and empathy
for those countries that's important
that that was a big what I call a big
success so the state existed and the
Russia was the country who donated the
borders so in the end Minister Kubus
estimated that Yalta was working in
Poland was working to Poland's advantage
in the sense of of of border and in a
sense of existing those independence
postulates but independent states so
many directions were set up full
sovereignty and independence war was
regained in international scene European
choice was done Western orientation
Western security orientation was
established and inner and and mid term
goals where as I said set up and it may
be some up that scuba cesky actions for
peaceful challenge showed both capacity
and skills to act with the creativity
empathy and non-violence in a conflict
situation that was masterpiece I think
and scuba cesky else his place among
greatest polish foreign minister
another important history I believe good
political good geopolitical situation
continued after his termination of
office but and that was good period in
the sense that the the gulls which were
set up we're being implemented I mean
the Europe agreement was signed then the
preparation was done for for our joining
the European Union four steps and then
negotiation was open on our joining of
NATO the negotiation start or up on our
in 1898 on our joining of of European
Union but period of drift as a period of
drift has started and what I mean is
lack of serious thinking in strategic
terms in terms of long-term period time
terms of territory in terms of future
threats in terms of new nature of
threats around in terms of our resources
and our instruments we have in a foreign
policy everybody was helping in Poland
about achieving our strategic goals we
are member of NATO and we are member of
you and history ends quoting Francis
Fukuyama history never ends we know it
well and then it was more and more
visible than joining this organization
is just the beginning and not the end is
the beginning of Poland's foreign and
security policy and we are coming with
empty hands I think to this organization
so in such it in such an environment of
antennas in strategy strategical
thinking we invented that we are best
I have United States and we start to
bridge Europe his United States we start
to bridge Russia with Western Europe so
we are really an infant power in the
rent that that was a symptom of illness
I believe because because in Poland
foreign security policies there is no
question of choosing options for America
or Europe for NATO and for European
Union both are pillars of Poland's
foreign and security policy so the
question is not to choose one option and
name it first and this second the
question of the problem and the ongoing
illness in Polish debate on foreign and
security policy is and how to make how
to play on the piano using both hands
together I can remember from my
childhood my parents have an ambition to
make and to plan for me the career of
pianist and I had a teacher and pennies
and teacher after a few weeks told me
Andre you will never play good after you
can use your both hands to play don't
concentrate on Iran right hand but use
also your your left hand this is what I
remember from my childhood and this is
what I apply here in my logic before
before you that we we decided to play
only one hand and this one hand was an
80 and us while european union i believe
is the equally important if not more
important pillar of poland security in
long term in long term because NATO is a
ma in the end NATO is about emergency
issues and
European Union is about daily business
European after we declared to be a big
power and to breach Germany with United
States and German colleague liberal good
German asked me angry how much straight
you have was United States so I felt
from oh that's interesting we had 120
times more yes so that that's the role
we can play in bridging what the problem
we really are confronted with is to
breach but not continents but to breach
our options in national politics to
breach NATO or American option with
European Union option option and make
them 14 countries country security then
then being thrown from one piano to
another and to playing just loop one
sometimes blues and sometimes mazurka
yes that that's not the that would be
the policy condemned to faylene and I
believe it we will not we will not
continue we will not continue this this
well of course this is not my point to
weaken Poland's you us or metal
relations contrary I would subscribe
myself to the Atlantis school of
thinking in security but it said the
Atlantis is in case of Poland needs
europeanization of your security policy
our voice in NATO and our voice in
Washington is weak and meaningless after
we represent the opinion of European
Union even for Timothy Garton ash thing
a thinking on
Britain's role in bridging two
continents he asked the the similar
question why should polish German or
Spanish leader could walk over London
Bridge to reach Washington American
president to speak to Rome or to Paris
yeah and the same the same problem is
with Poland especially after we remember
that Poland is much weaker much weaker
partner and country then great Great
Britain is and the mistake we did was
the bigger because our siding with us
what present was presented in European
Union as a mean or instrument to
strengthen our position within the
European Union partners were astonished
first of all the proportion that the
proportion of partners presentations
collaborated on this in a second this is
contrary to European Union logic of
decision-making you cannot translate
your external weight of external powers
nation and to transfer them into the
decision-making process in the union
because other partners would disagree
with you because it would it it would
disorganized internal decision-making
process well what is terribly important
for the European Union to to stay
sovereign in the taking decisions so
that was that the example of how
dangerous for Poland is to be other
ambitious in her to become pretentious
in her foreign and security policy and
two bridges potentials which are much
bigger than the
earrings Poland is successful middle
power and that's our loan that's our law
and that's enough that was big
remarkable success that was great
victory of middle power but stay there
don't escalate your powers don't don't
be exposed to overstretching what we
what we adjust what it is as the second
poorest member of the European Union and
to have a yes in foreign and security
policy to have a position we need to
grow and in our need to grow European
Union is the best media is the best
organization is the best chance we have
and has the European Union state
european economic community community as
it was before nine to 11 could say okay
that it is wise and needed that we base
our foreign and security policy on nato
and on the United States but European
Union has changed dramatically since 89
European Union has a common foreign
security policy and please don't don't
think that this is this is weak policy
to make enlargement to accept to new
member countries hundred million people
who freely and willingly did it this is
weak foreign and security policy to
launch the program to extend the zone of
stability and democracy and human rights
around the Europe covering almost 20
states covering 400 million people in
the common area of trade democracy and
human right this is European
neighbourhood policy this is weak fine
secure
policy it wants it come on now now
European Union is not in the cleanses
European Union is growing in all terms
common currency European security and
defence policy just few months ago
European defence agency was created
that's terribly important that means
that the trade in European Union biggest
in the world biggest in the world will
be will also cover trade in arms in near
future so the single market will cover
also military equipment it's hundred
billion dollars a year military
equipment in European standings so that
I cannot accept okay acha locate this
question we are in a free country so
they there's a full freedom of
expression and opinions of course but I
thought I i don't think that European
Union is in crisis I I would dream that
we always in the future that we infuser
have have such a crisis as we are now
this is normal European Union is fewer
link with crisis that's good conflicts
are normal we love them we'll have to
solve that we and we are prepared to
solve the conflict and so long as they
are expressed and the language of
conflict approach and conflict solving
is based on European Twitter's yeah this
is from Professor vantage book on united
Europe as yet not zonal oppa my logic
also supplied from so the conflict is
not a problem for Europe with conflict
where conflict are and conflict will be
around us this is element
of international scene this element of
internal scene and we are prepared we we
build our treaties to solve the conflict
without the spire to live in the world
without conflicts Nazis aspired to live
in a world without conflict once they
solve the problem once and for all
communists aspired to live in a world
without conflict once they once they
solve the problem for once and for that
all ends though idealistic idealistic
Fantas Midori's ended in in in rivers in
rivers of blood only so we are used to
conflict and that that's not not not the
problem what does an engines okay sir
the European Union and European Union is
fully prepared to correspond with
specific Poland's need in security first
of all sustainable development economic
growth trait research in approach to to
peace and 2 and 2 security good conduct
conduct a good conduct in arms trend
regular border regimes a good
neighbourhood policy energy energy
supplies and dependency all economic
aspect of security are being taken into
account in common foreign security
policy and European security and defence
policy so this is why my point is that
that our daily business is connected to
European Union and he European Union has
capacity to deliver in the field of
foreign policy and in security policy I
have no time to to deal with the issue
of burden sharing with among Europe and
United
and among Europe and European Union but
it's not the story only to count or to
take into account military spending
that's it's only half of the picture
European Union is a huge spender in
another in other sectors of burden
sharing so to sum up what we really need
in our foreign and security policy is
not bridging EU and US and European
Union and NATO but put house in order
and to bridge the options in national
policy to restore the balance now as I
said try to play on two pianos and we
need to play on one piano and the piano
to stay with this artistic comparison
the piano is European Union the melody
is United States and NATO and the player
who is player we are playing parlor this
player and of course European Union is
play another battle pollen is play that
was my message to you thank you marks
and for me it's sort of a happy moment
in the sense that I hope that for all he
was a service
is basically a specialist on Polish
American relations sitting to my
furthest left and a specialist on polish
EU relation seemed to my immediate left
or both of them kind of delivered on
their specialties and that's fine I
don't know free hands in the middle
because there's a very big pond between
those two confidence i'm in the middle
European Union my bro I will go to my
remarks through it really just a few
points which may or may not necessarily
be important when mr. P saw Steve was
referring to the polish Prime Minister's
remarks in securing national consensus I
search starts to bring to emit an
American ear like one of George Bush's
statements about the national consensus
where was the national consensus been
polling decided to go into Iraq nobody
asked they're the only national
consensus there was during the Miller
government was when ninety-one percent
of people who were asked voted that mr.
Miller's government wasn't the good one
of course he lost his job a similar
national consensus met mr. Belka who
ultimately had a disapproval rating in
mid teens so there is such a idea
concept is national consensus but it
applies to governments and doesn't seem
really to apply to policy Ukrainian
integration was mentioned by mr.
kosowski and I think
terrific moment to examine the Polish
record so to speak and here i would i
would waive my finger at the european
union and say that it was the poles who
were most interested in what was going
on on their eastern border and very
often much to the dismay of brussels
policymakers who weren't happy with the
policies that the poles were proposing
just a week ago in this room on november
10th we had a conference on europe and
europe in the mirror of transatlantic
relations some misconduct and it's a
loser and we had Danny cohn-bendit here
and a number of European specialists and
one of them took the occasion to talk
about the obscure Polish government of
mr. McKinley's surely an obscure Polish
government because he's not a very
well-known politician because he just
got voted in but to mr. Martin cabbages
defense and to the defense of Poland
came daniel cohn-bendit who immediately
jumped in and said this is an example of
what a country like poland can do inside
the european union look what it did in
Ukraine hit drove European Union policy
next door that's a very strong state so
what I'm hearing from both parties is
that there are policy options that are
sometimes explored in the case of
Ukraine one of my even ask the question
was it really the Polish government that
was active in your frame or was
aleksander questions he was active what
about the policy planning units of the
Polish foreign minister who works there
now and what are their specialties is it
is it possible to imagine that in a very
short period of time they can combine
something that they have had seven years
of experience harmonizing with NATO with
cutting military forces from 430,000
down to 140,000 right now changing the
military doctrine of Poland several
times in order to meet the new
environment that the Polish government
founded subject seven years it's been
doing this and it's quite natural that
it's had in effect not to mention going
to Iraq and the responsibility of taking
on the leadership of a multinational
division which the polls have never done
is it should we really be so demanding
of Polish policy planners with had only
really two years of experience with what
is really a much tougher environment the
European Union my colleague rj how she
loved each tells me about how difficult
the bureaucracy and process is and how
hard it is to fight for your national
interest inside this new organism which
has 24 other countries fighting for
their individual
national interests as well is it
conceivable that in such a short period
of time no matter how well school you
are and how much experience you have a
foreign ministry or an economics
ministry can develop a harmonizing
tactic that will somehow balance the two
I'm not sure that it's this is a fair
question to ask politicians in simple
country what don't we see in the very
brief expose of the new polish Prime
Minister with respect to foreign
relations you may recall mr. Collins ax
back in 1990 1991 at one point floated
what we call a trial balloon and he
talked about so-called not obese which
was an idea doomed to failure but
concerned cooperation with those
countries lying between Russia and
Poland from the Baltic Sea from the
Black Sea a funny thing that idea came
up just a few months ago in Poland once
again this time the person who was
speaking about it was Alexander question
st is there anybody in poland seriously
thinking about some kind of inter Mario
some kind of revived Promethean movement
a closer cooperation with countries that
see better arrangement than the one
that's there right now I don't have an
answer to that and I wonder if either of
our speakers in bridgeville part of our
second speakers discussion this
afternoon bridge building is fine and I
have to say that polls are very good at
building bridges there are lots of
bridges around the world that have been
built by poles engineering is a Polish
specialty the chief engineer of columbia
university is sitting in this room and
he's polish everything works very well
it is university thank you but bridge
building between the United States and
the European Union I don't know if that
isn't too much of a challenge for a
country like pole which is basically
what our colleague said I would really
like to know whether the policy planning
units in the foreign ministry of
undergone some kind of traumatic
syndrome I can't say that I know enough
about the people who do this for a
living I will say that a country like
the United States has lots of people
planning policy and the United States
regularly falls into his own traps does
Poland do any better I somehow think
that Poland is not doing so badly so
that's the extent of my remarks let me
turn it over to the both of you for ya a
rejoinder and then I'll invite the
audience to ask questions thank you very
much mr. chairman indeed there is a lot
of a lot of money on my plate now so let
me try to to make some some remarks in
response to what what
both of my distinguished panelists said
first of all let me address the issue of
national concerns maybe I was conscious
maybe I was not clear i referred mostly
two day period between the collapse of
communism and entering to EU as the
period in which the strategic goals of
Poland were clearly defined and were met
by well by something that can be called
a national consensus the issue of Iraq
clearly our extent that that that a
period of time although we might discuss
what it really meant that the society
was against the participation of Poland
in that operation was only limited to
the military part or did it also take
under under the consideration the
political implications but this is this
is a subject for very long discussion
well i think that the our polish
strategy towards the towards our eastern
neighbors is simple I mean it's Europe
it's about bringing the person
perspective for a closer cooperation we
are we have to be our we're serious and
we have to be very very responsible in
how we address those issues with our
eastern eastern neighbors of course we
would like to see greater integration of
Ukraine maybe in the future belarus and
the holder
Europe meant as the are as the
organization based on a very specific
values and and freedoms and i think that
the opponent is interested in
interesting to our eastern neighbors
only in that sense that it could somehow
facilitate their quest for a greater
integration that we can that that we can
share with them our experience but first
of all by our presence in indy EU and
NATO we demonstrate to them that these
are achievable goals that this is not
something that this is beyond their you
reach so this is the value of poland i
would say which stem which comes from
this but you know warsaw blog or
communist bloc and was able to break
through and get to do to EU and NATO and
and basically give some hope to two
nations with who are still deprived for
making this kind of choices well you
know about european union and nato of
course i am i am i well i am very much
aware about all advantages that european
union is offering to poland and why and
why opponent who wanted to join the EU
nevertheless the opinion is not a
military alliance your opinion can offer
a lot of incentives in terms of
development in terms of our prosperity
but it doesn't have it doesn't offer
this the same kind of military
guarantees as nato offers and in that
sense we don't see any competition
between
EU and NATO moreover i would i would say
that the opponent's position within the
EU is even stronger because of this
strong transatlantic link and we don't
want to replace or build bridges between
Germany for instance and United States
we don't want to replace any traditional
us li you know from from obvious reasons
what we want to do is to bring more
sensitivity on you know to Europe and
the United States about the importance
of this strategy clings link which has
been a source of hope for Poland
throughout all these decades of being
subject to the outside domination and we
still believe that there is there is a
strong argument for this community to
continue so I don't really see any
attempt on the polish side to and to
replace somebody to or to build build
bridges we want to strengthen witches
don't build them because they are
already existing and 11 not drink my
presentation and presentation I said
that the Prime Minister managed our
possible engagement in Afghanistan it
wasn't the case he it was in the
background material smoke his ugly not
in his actual switch so I need to make
the scarification thing just two
sentences out of the European Union and
another and they
and complimentary either European Union
and NATO are coming closer and closer
and I'm not not opposite in communist
time that was popular popular maxim was
that NATO was invented to keep Germans
down Americans in in Europe thin and
Russians out today's matter is not about
these girls and longer today's motto is
about to keep Germans in in European
frame in European Union frame to keep us
in still and to keep Russia in not out
in the only lift and the European Union
is about the same goals with one
difference that some Member States would
like to see us out of the of Europe yeah
that's the difference we we are
confronted with and but I am optimist we
can solve it because there are no real
that no real vital different positions
between EU and US and NATO thank you
very good let's open up the floor
equations
I have a question regarding the current
situation in program the new government
be trading forum is a minority
government and therefore relies upon the
support of parties which we know have
not been very friendly to the other
entry to the European Union and
therefore i just wanted to what degree
they demands on the foreign policy may
have these parochial aspects of which of
the prince Marshall tomato or internal
development not to be open with you I
have no I have no final opinion of this
new government because I'm to distance
and I'm happy I'm happy here to be
concentrated on academic affairs and not
on political affairs so but I would be
that until Stefan Miller is where it is
I mean in a foreign ministry I I would
be I would be of me I would be a good
how well it would happened these are
elements probably elements out of the
internal gamin and fighting this some
this demagogue or populists appeal to
renegotiate the renegotiate the European
Union accession treaty and especially
from mr. angela is demagogic call you
know that mr. leper received few tens
thousands lata a year as a direct
payment for having for having land for
having arable land just for nothing for
having land yeah so he's our benefactor
of the of the situation as most as most
polished farmers so I think it might be
it might
a political trap for mr. lakker and III
would wish to see that that Prime
Minister marching cabbage or jaroslav
catch a ski who is architect of this of
this non coalition brother magnet i
would say non collision minority
government will be able to benefit from
from from this demagogues attack that's
all I can say sorry oh thank you very
much maybe I can actually have another
man for the most of the day I decided to
sit choir apparently because my position
is almost half over there which I can
see for the past four hours but I have
to say something here
we went listen to
a really brilliant speech of that we
begin sleep come as always was in case
of his car insurance load of policemen
algorithmic analysis famous forum for
what I respected in protective factor I
would somehow magically even critically
very attractive concept which was picked
up from in stages assertive curriculum
of convo Poland or foreign policy and
with somehow given in the eris as
something with a little bit demonize it
home politics in the nephew to become
whether we are
effectively curriculum or not is further
than but asking death but speak about at
the end or the impression external
impression in Europe and also here is
happening on the character dimension has
been happening in common recently then I
say that we should analyze also the
domestic situation we can figure out
foreign policy making the most used Lord
has made estate much less in country and
I almost haven't heard the word people
here to discuss today just plenty of
frustration with community of toner some
sociologists keep saying that kind of
classic and from the escape from freedom
that the speed of change of the past 15
years have been too fast too dynamic
that the people have to reorient their
mentalities and they have daily habits
and many many other things the risk of
losing the governor who's standing which
is something quite normal in the US but
in the society event 02 generation had
been in important but currently kind of
a job it's a fundamental change of
pattern of life now how does it
correspond to foreign policy making in
my garden this generally give it an
Australian always had certain impact on
the climate especially in the past 23
years Henry European was heavily
committed by simple and use that virus
police had broken from left to right for
the invalid benefit
they are constituency's and please do
not forget that the current time
speaking about I mean the year two
thousand five was cynically because we
had the elections thought for the house
for both chambers of our Parliament and
very very shortly later we have
recovered and I would try to add
something or think about major concerns
as far as the near future of our foreign
policy making is concerned I would for a
mistake that the nothing that can be
seen as dangerous as the threat of
assertive parochialism it can really be
seen on the stage on you see we have
there are some rules of forward voices
on the common political scene but when
we figure out the rooster for me
capital behavior we must not forget
about also phenomenal behaviors and
appearance in statements in Russia it's
a simple innocent statement of myself
nothing more the whole story with with
the victory parade in Moscow on 60
aniversario
when were to conclusion was very study
that Polish community we all know how it
was play also on the Russian side
for his presence up there how deep and
full conversion for the debate
employment on whether the polish
president should participate should go
to Moscow or not and i went to call all
the tunes the phone collector calls
music it was just the overall discussion
in the country which is open free and
its own had also getting out of the blue
as heart the Polish Russian relations
are concerned is same or similar
analysis could be done with polish
German relations I totally subscribe to
that the bejesus opinion that the father
further a week conciliation or standing
before the German reconciliation has a
crucial meaning for many many many
aspects of our nightly problem as well
for our positioning our general opinion
Susanna voltages but but still its
residual various complex
complicated for each of the generation
of all very complicated for the people
who lived through the war who somehow
they were victims for the world or
another losses of their years of their
wealth devastation of the country and so
and for many people who don't it's very
difficult to comprehend all of those may
be marginal German are so easy to to be
amplified opponent voices about that
famous intentionally compounded the
center of the extent that will be
located too many holes is it German a
phobia is it parokya as assertive
parochialism I don't thank you very
thank you
my name is dr. vampire I think that
there you have you play your left hand
little department just to improve the
sliding relation between Poland and
Russia it is hurting our deployment
Eddie who is winning German they bypass
Poland gasps going to Germany now we
cannot export the nice to Russian there
there are some complain of the farmers
from the eastern part of the problem
there is standard of living has declined
since a border was closed so i'm just
very important and have really use your
left hand or disturb people and one
support i disagree completely with from
a previous training answer adeptus
poland should have a strong arm first we
are is a modest modest mother and strong
modest just to be able and ourself we
are in native we are your pain you you
we don't need strong
and this is the wasting of the money we
cannot have forced from harm and the
last thing I would just quote them the
statement of Dalai Lama who said that
work in our fabulous are obsolete
absolutely also this is not a solution
in our present gubler work period thank
you very much oh yeah let me let me just
say a few sentences about about Russia
it's true we have experiencing some
difficulties with exporting our
agricultural product to Russia but there
is there's been a very interesting
development for the last I believe year
old anymore during this period of well
let's say on the exchange of statements
of history at the same time the Polish
exports to Russia are increased by one
hundred percent or even more and
especially in this agricultural products
so that shows that you know that there
is still a plenty of room and potential
for the development of constructive
normal relations and I really hope that
the current issues will be so very
quickly because what Colin wants to do
with in the relations in the
relationship
Russia is to engage in kind of
partnership or a partner like trade
economy cultural relations and we don't
see any any reason why it it is it is
not possible it is not possible to
achieve well to the arm for Armed Forces
I think that this is the one of the
lessons we have learned from the Polish
history the we need to be ready to
confront any any type of fred's
reference to our independence and
sovereignty because this is not for us
it is not a theoretical discussion
whether there is a kind of threat or
menace or you know a conflict situation
you know even in my short life I
remember the tanks on the streets well
they were the Polish time they were
during the march on Rome I understand
the difference but i think that the
sense of of the importance of of the
security policy in poland is very is
very strong and this is what i would say
differ probably in a sense poland from
its Western European neighbours who
developed in a completely different
situation where just one sentence for
each topic on Russia you are perfectly
right my opinion is also such that no
other country in Europe is more
interested in Russia being stable
prosperous and democratic country than
Poland is and this is not probably not
because of our love of Russia which
would be exaggeration but this is in our
best interest that Russia is democratic
and stable country so we should draw a
conclusion from them that we should we
should support those false
who are for better relations with with
Russia but it takes two to tango that so
did it on Russia side that there must be
partner and sometimes we lack the
apartment by sometimes ah I think that
present relation present not present not
after this meet embargo but but now we
are we have a best-ever situation in
Polish Russian relations also there are
some problems on army now this
never-ending discussion about the role
of the army in democratic countries
about defending piece about being
disarmed too much about the reasons for
war for results to force and violence
but if you if your logic is that we need
we do not need an army because we are
members of the European Union and NATO
so my logic would be such if all members
of European Union and NATO have no
armies who will defend us in case of
need cool so in it the best the best you
can do is to cooperate with your
neighbors with your partners and friends
but to keep in mind what what Marshall
Ironside said this is from 17th century
trust God and keep your powder dry
that's they that would be my final final
at work we have one last comments last
question from dr. system
no vision I have pressure because yeah
for institution politically elected the
constituency of its own boom say
president roller office government and
setup and government is majority
government same is pretty fragmented and
we juxtapose ideas of their place in
Poland in Europe how what is the center
which one of the c2 is prevailing in
policymaking foreign policy making now
how would you predict this question well
I don't also difficult question of the
five others look it up that was the
question which marshalls you should ski
was confronted in the beginning of my of
26 probably how to how to govern the
this country shouldered that said that
there are three institutions and the
government is amination an emanation of
parliament which is the same and the
same has too much power in in contrast
with the weak weak government they that
was the problem of the interwar period
and this is still our our problem so
they are after thinking a bit of this
and after following some wise people i
think that they under chance for better
democracy for better quality of
governance in poland is a change of
constitution to make to make government
stronger and to make parliament not so
powerful in changing government into the
moment and that and for that reason we
would need it will need changes in in
the constitution without it you will
still still what you can offer is to
appeal to goodwill and the appeals
the goodwill we're all appeals were
already done and belt nothing so that I
think that we should that we should
enter my legal political way and to
check try to change on our Constitution
on on the model of stronger stronger
government or stronger executive yeah
I'm sure dr. petitions well unless you
think it's difficult to join this
discussion to discussions kind of
historical changes they make just three
short one on current problems and
special in the discussion whether
important person
seems to diversity doesn't take into
account one basic change
and so
the United Nations and every week on
Monday the kinds of emissions need and
decide for many and also produce
policies continue to come before I was
approached ambassador later and I'll say
that a lot of decision finding political
participation so I would say that a
paradox is but i would say that for the
first time our history we are really
having a global policy because another
officials will believe me to express on
many issues on which we must present our
position today discussing different word
problems
first to change bilateral relations with
me because it's often i am saying
security of any country starts with
bilateral basis with me so the change
all our neighbors in purpose so that was
the budget in systems if we had new 770
term papers and with all again we're
stand with you
relationship is again protein for the
first time we had this kind of bilateral
relationship with all our main labor
despite some tensions which exists in
relations professional second but
nothing that is a new dimension of our
original course Central Europe never in
history has generated any form of
regional coverage and under say that at
the beginning of 90s where the course
participation new forms of regional of
things kevin bishop century became
afraid error council of baltic states
these are see structures they don't have
any direct security dimension but they
introduce some kind of a heavy of
constructive regional of
and the third they think it was to join
NATO and congenital in unity and of
course of the security situation
very cool but probably what most people
at the time lost before work on
Univision because the original killer is
not the question of the last 50 years
detective ever and always in the minds
of many Europeans Americans over the
septum and Europe was kind of Italian I
wouldn't qualify to be effective and
humane about the thinking behind joint
women panting was before become this
historical
Thank You vespa toffee can thank you
John
you